[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we've new wheels a pre-celebration for
the big day huh I make your partner baby
that glass ceiling deserves give it up
summit worldwide sports management's
newest partner boys club every days you
don't connect well with men just stay in
your lane I don't trust women who don't
get dudes like I don't trust a man with
no eyebrows are too many keys I know
someone you should talk to
I can help you commit with me why don't
we have some tea this is like dirt
oh that's just jasmine tea if you don't
count the weed and the ple okay
[Applause]
hello welcome back miss Davis thank god
this one didn't die on me
starting today no more drinking at work
hey that's too much information or
anything I think we here after last
night yeah that's what happens when
tequila meets and desperation okay stop
saying things it shouldn't be saying to
your boss holy crap
can you hear my inner thoughts I mean
stuff that cloud you're walking through
that's my farts I thought black people
stopped turning - you have to get out
where were to complain about men trying
to keep you down do we have any meetings
on the books nothing yet except the
private poker game tonight this is not a
curse after Tet Perez
the lady is doing it the big boys table
huh oh crap
I'm bluffing these fools I'm missing
Real Housewives check finally has a
winning hand why am I thinking in the
third person I smell toast my happiness
throw weight I have chosen my pocket
[Music]